[Musique]
ouais parce que moi j'ai dire un truc je
suis propre c'est neuf ça vous êtes donc
peace and peace and love for hire pas en
même temps si tout est tous en même
temps
mais bon pas trop exagérer non plus je
ne savais pas que les pages - servait à
faire des smokings mais ça me considère
que le mâle correspond à la taille 6 ans
et la femelle à la taille quatre ans
passés un baby gros sur mesure ça mais
c'est scandaleux effectivement c'est la
même chose que les phoques bible de la
mode va passer quand ça va être passée
et on va changer vous pensez que la mode
des phoques va passer bien sûr
on sait que pascal c'est vrai on va être
amené à disparaître bien sûr tout ça ça
va il n'y a pas de présenter
personnellement vous avez déjà porté des
fourrures non et si j'ai porté ça mais
c'est du cedus et du factice un plan sur
les boutons pactisent monsieur était
factice combien de bébés factice doit-on
tuer pour faire confectionner une perte
de ces bourses ne sais pas moi-même eu
pour moi de 2,2 au mois de bébé quand
vous cautionnez le massacre des bébés
factice pour confectionner des buttes
oui pardon monsieur qui pensez vous donc
les gens qui massacrent des profanes
téléphoner vous mais ces trente secondes
alors couper la tête aux pingouins
non non aux gens qui couvre tout en bois
c'est une info de quoi je suis pas du
tout voir l'école s'il vous plaît tic
est
j'ai passé six à prendre
quoiqu'il du lézard vous savez vous-même
un col en fourrure c'est du synthétique
mais vous avez déjà pensé au regard de
la maman synthétique quand on massacre
devant elle son bébé
non je vous avais
j'imagine que vous aimez oui oui c'est
quelque chose de moderne en tout cas ça
se passe un jour on peut pas vraiment
l'ignorait mais vous attendez c'est bien
mais on l'a trop de bonnes réactions
tout le monde aime bien on a besoin
d'avoir un peu la vie des deux côtés
dont vous allez dire que vous l'aimez
pas du tout comme ça nous ça nous permet
d'équilibrer le sujet mademoiselle on
tourne mademoiselle que pensez-vous de
smaïn haut
j'aime pas trop quoi a fait rire pas
vraiment je crois que non ils essayent
mais il arrive pas physiquement vous le
trouvez comment
il n'est pas génial et en plus je crois
qu'il fait mal
il est fait très mal son travail staline
c'est un petit trop drôle je n'ai pas vu
sur scène mais ce que j'ai aperçu la
télévision est très bien mais si on fait
un sujet sur lui mais tout le monde aime
bien on est un petit peu dans la merde
là monsieur ça tourne monsieur que
pensez-vous de smaïn j'aime pas du tout
il est arrivé trop vite il a été un peu
propulsé si vous aviez quelque chose à
lui dire en face ce serait quoi lui dire
en face
hyper désagréable qui retourne chez lui
messieurs si vous aviez quelque chose à
dire en face à smaïn ce serait quoi qui
retourne chez lui bah en fait ça veut
dire j'aime pas trop en fait oui une
botte pas tellement c'est son genre je
pense un peu vulgaire quoi bas en plus
il ya une vraie tête de con il est
horrible et lamentable il est nul il est
grossier vulgaire il se moque de tous
respectent rien je n'aime pas s'il est
en passe de mâts je crois que je
passerai au visage
c'est une question un peu
spécial que vous me demandez là j'ai des
difficultés à répondre oui je suis prête
à venir en aide aux parents orphelins
personnellement vous seriez prête à
faire quoi pour ces gens-là parents
d'orphelins ça dépend ce qui m'est
proposé en fin juillet ce qui est
suggéré
il faut agir intelligemment sortie en
boîte à des sorties en boîte
en bas la rouille
sortie en boîte
mais sorti en boîte pourquoi pas
voyez-vous pour eux et aux parents aux
parents d'orphelins mais ces décisions
feuillets ils n'ont pas de parents c'est
idiot votre question on va faire quoi
pour aider les parents d'orphelins à
sortir du trou et votre avis deux à
l'heure actuelle je crois que c'est le
gouvernement qui dépense beaucoup
d'argent où il ne le faudrait pas qu'il
faut mais de dépenser sur ces choses là
et non lorsqu'il fait le monsieur seriez
vous prêt à venir en aide aux parents
d'orphelins oui parce que je trouve
qu'ils ont besoin de décompression
connaissez vous même des parents
orphelins pourquoi actuellement
voilà vous posez des choses un peu
compliquées
ce sont des gens qui sont un peu comme
vous au bout du rouleau et j'en ai
encore des mecs à faire donc beaucoup
l'eau je suis pas au bout du rouleau
pense que c'est difficile pour un
orphelin de garder un contact accès par
an
soit assez dur quoi seriez vous prête à
venir en aide aux parents d'orphelins
aux parents de refaire oui oui oui vous
feriez quoi pour les aider à sentir des
troupes s'effacent pas la télé ça un
ancien de la radio vous avez pratiqué le
double jeu vous en politique parce que
vous appelez le doublage et les
promesses électorales à langue de bois
les magouilles les affaires non pas du
tout c'est dans quel mouvement vous je
suis au rpr au tfc à vous c'est connu
c'est connaître le mouvement de jacques
chirac que je démarre démarre en
comprendre bon on peut se tutoyer ce
sera plus conviviale
ok donc tu penses que toi il ya trop de
double jeu dans la politique ou ayant un
double jeu
est ce que pour faire député il faut
coucher pour réussir je connais pas ça
il fallait que j'aille toute la
population je crois que qui font un
nouveau langage il faut être une
nouvelle vue de la france il faut un
patriotisme de son pays et de la défense
des intérêts alors on coupe tout et j'ai
mis ma pauvreté mignonne le double jeu
en politique pour quoi pour vous c'est
quoi
double jeu monsieur il faut pas le jouer
vous les jouez vous monsieur j'ai jamais
joué aux jurés on va parler plus vrai
plus direct on va tutoyer c'est plus
convivial ok qu'est ce que tu penses du
double jeu toi c'est à dire les
magouilles tout ça tu as touché où il a
touché mes yeux dans les yeux
non non de quoi donc jamais fait quoi
jamais des fois des enveloppes sous la
table on voit que le dessus il n'y a pas
d' enveloppe qui passent en dessous mais
vous n'avez que ça à dire aux hommes
politiques
le double chez nos politiques pour vous
c'est quoi je ne sais pas je ne pratique
par edward il pratique un peu il est
vrai que les français n'aiment pas
toujours entendre un salon de vérité est
que ils ont souvent au bout du compte
les parlementaires qui le méritent
voyez là tout le monde a décroché à
votre phrase était longue c'est
peut-être un petit peu ça aussi la
langue de bois no non parce que on ne
résume pas une situation par des
formules très court par des gros titres
à sensation non je crois que les gens
notre côté on n'a pas compris une drogue
de ce que vous avez dit que c'est vous
qui nous soit vous qui le dites moi je
suis steam pas l'intelligence des
français et la capacité qu'ils ont de
comprendre des phrases donc si vous
n'êtes pas capable de comprendre des
phrases donc moi je n'y peux rien sion
le trac accessible toi raconte et crack
qu'est ce que c'est que ce vocabulaire
des villes vous alimentez je crois
effectivement tout 7,7 sort des dettes
itude à la fois ironique critique
sélection comme à l'égard de fonctions y
compris votre votre activité dans
déclare alors écoutez c'est vrai que je
décroche je m'excuse je décroche
aussi je dérange mais le journalisme
rock'n'roll non on va la refaire on va
se tutoyer c'est plus convivial c'est
comment votre prénom robert ok je vais
t'appeler baby baby baby le double je
t'en penses quoi
bah j'en pense peu de choses mais lolo
la ville et double je t'en penses quoi
l'anneau fera dit pas ce double jeu et
je pense que c'est pas du tout ce qui
fait gagner en politique écoutez
rock'n'roll ta g s'est pas tu connais le
moins possible et ainsi balayé les
régimes
qui pratiquent la langue de bois c'est
dégueulasse le point non c'est d'être
ridicule c'est pas trop chier dans la
creuse c'est pas trop ça c'est pas chier
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça parce
que le nom moi je vous invite
on fait du boulot tu as envie vous
organisez des clubs puisque king des
ambiances depuis le plus de buts 2
qu'est ce que c'est que les activités ou
cabaye à des activités wiwa concrètement
12,6 industriel touristique culturel et
tout ce que vous voulez dans la toile
via des 27 dans la creuse oui aussi
venez je vous laisse prévoir un petit
enfant ciao demain je vais pas bouffer
annoncera père question vous présentez
vous bernard généreux député des
yvelines
de quel groupe vous êtes du groupe
socialiste c'est heavy metal enfin
nantes un bon groupe c est pourquoi vous
êtes député depuis combien de temps
dix ans est-ce que c'est plus facile
quand on est député pour se tirer des
gonzesses à ce que ça aide
ça je pense que cela dépende pas du rôle
de
et de la profession que l'on fait quand
on est député est ce que c'est plus
facile avec les gonzesses après pour
conclure coûté ce n'est pas une question
sérieuse posée nous une question sur la
fin il faut vous remettre en question
pour moi sérieuse parce que des fois on
est sur un coup on échange on est à deux
doigts et l'ananas e4 je comprends pas
du tout son soutien
parfois il est là qui sont impressionnés
d'aynac on n'aurait pas pensé me retirer
mais comme on le député hop on peut leur
mettre une cartouche c'est une
plaisanterie non c'est une vraie
question
messieurs juste une question vous vous
teniez la main ce qu'il y a des
relations homosexuelles
parmi les hommes politiques des rapports
ou ce n'est pas la main d'abord si vous
êtes caresser un petit peu vous avez eu
un début du jeu vous avez une question
jean-pierre quand on est connu c'est
plus facile avec les gonzesses que c'est
plus difficile si forcément plus
difficile parce qu'il met des lunettes
noires vraiment une question quand on
est un homme politique est ce que c'est
plus facile avec les gonzesses après
d'abord d'abord pourquoi me tutoyez
alors est-ce que je t'aime bien
bon vous avez sympathie en a pas on n'a
pas vu qu ensemble comme ça parce que
j'ai pas voulu
il est temps semble donc je suis la
barrière le député maire de pau et vous
avez payé d'attouchements sexuels avec
j'adore yvette et je crois que ça vaut
mieux la doré que tout le reste très
vite qu'elle est bonne mais il va être
jeté pas jacques simplement est ce que
le fait d'être connu en politique ça
sert avec les gonzesses
c'est à dire que depuis que je
et rencontré ma femme qui est
fantastique
alors les gonzesses ne me concerne plus
plu du tout tu t'es fait coupé par un
veto vaut pas du tout vraiment on se
tutoie pas alors un et on se vouvoie pas
voilà dit on ne parle pas assez bon
voilà un rock n roll un cinéma je
comprends pas je vois je vois pas
pourquoi ils peuvent l'être les juifs le
sont les protestants leçon je vois pas
pourquoi compris vrai un homme du désir
d'aimer de la chair et autres choses qui
peuvent approfondir le désir de vivre à
deux
et encore mieux en communion quoi donc
vous êtes pour le mariage des prêtres
entre bien c'est entre eux le mariage ne
prétend t non alors là l'eau non c'est
bravo vous pensez qu'il est mieux qu'il
continue de se cacher que les prêtres se
fâche se cache cache leur amour
moi je préfère oui si je connaissais un
prêtre qui ont qui était un peu plus
rapprochée que les autres mais j'avais
quand j'avais 12 ans tripoter un petit
peu par un prêtre les mains ouais ouais
mais bon c'est
ouais quoique ouais mais non mais c'est
contradictoire la vocation on avait
pensé au mariage et cette époque avec
lui ah non non c'était comme un père
j'ai passé ma mais non on va faire un
petit peu assez ce que tu peux tuer pour
aucun mariage quels qu'ils soient
pourquoi paul ibrahim ben c'est pas bon
donc vous êtes pour l'union libre en ce
qui concerne les prêtres ah oui chacun
fait ce qui lui plaît
lorsqu ils s'aiment aux écoutes et des
femmes racontent les histoires ne suis
pas homosexuel
comment le mariage des prêtres entre eux
oh my home à monseigneur qui en pince
pour un autre monseigneur même vous avez
déjà eu une relation une relation
sexuelle avec un prêtre et les soeurs
entre l appareil
l'ipad il est curé et les soeurs ça doit
se faire sur 20% tous les écuries et les
bergers allemands
bonjour madame on est en direct dans
trente secondes vous connaissez les
missions perdu de vue qu'un début les
enfants ou les personnes qui veulent oui
on enquête sur une personne qui a
disparu depuis quatre ans une dame qui a
sensiblement votre âge on l'avait
retrouvé on l'a reperdu ya la famille
sur le plateau on voudrait que vous
fassiez un petit témoignage on verra pas
votre visage on dit que vous êtes
geneviève de saint-agil jeu posé trois
questions 10 secondes 10 secondes dakar
eh bien oui nous avons retrouvé
geneviève de saint-agil après une
disparition de plus de 4 années alors
geneviève
où étiez-vous pendant toutes ces années
je n'aurais mardi ciel gris de paris et
j'ai voulu aller voir le où se trouvait
le soleil à thierry là bas malgré moi et
vous dit que vos deux enfants josélito
et mongolito sont en larmes il pour
regarde bien qu'il ya huit mois un autre
37 ans qu'est ce que vous avez à leur
dire à vos enfants et salut les gars
salut ça va c'est papa alors je reviens
bientôt à la maison est patent des
coucous ne riez pas c'est une émission
dramatique et il ya famille sur le
plateau enfin comme but que je suis
homosexuel que j'ai vendu mon corps et
que j'ai une petite cervelle d'oiseau
mais je crois que ce sont les larmes de
la sincérité
séquence émotion c'est vous qui revenez
1 et oui après quinze années de
disparition nous avons enfin retrouver
le capitaine craddock le capital
craddock
où étiez-vous capitaine depuis ses 15
ans c'était 15 ans vous avez disparu et
où étiez-vous capitaine mois genève
vous avez fait naufrage au large du cap
horn et depuis plus de nouvelles
rythmant
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pendant toutes
ces années alors junior vous vendez
toujours votre corps ah non non non
justement sorti maintenant de la
prostitution
on vivait maintenant exclusivement que
de la drogue non plus adélard mental et
on va faire des larmes parce que ccb
attend les jeunes ont un truc assez la
cité du cinéma
ne soyez pas penché la tête en arrière
ne souriez pas monsieur c'est l'émotion
à l'état pur
allez vous pleurez vous pleurer ou rire
ou pleurer oui mr prend désormais lire
d'accord vous l'aimez toujours oui bien
sûr c'est monique n'assiste pas à vous
êtes visiblement à bout de nerfs
c'est très très beau ccc poignant c'est
excitant
enfin un reportage sur l'étrave estime
aujourd'hui il y en a pas un
donc on vous demande de jouer le jeu
pour que nous on ramène des images ce
qu'on a alloué une équipe ça coûte très
cher donc vous faites le travesti une
minute je vous pose trois questions
ok 1 quand vous appelez votre prénom
eric eric je vous appelez eric thomas
manteaux voiles alors qu'on va aller
très très vite
vous êtes vous à faire partir un
personne venir
[Musique]
voilà temps des femmes la bouche le nez
voilà encore un peu wallard patron la
perruque
voilà permet via lé manteau tenez votre
bateau
ok erika vous vendez votre corps depuis
combien d'années
six mois vous faites vous fait combien
de clients par jour
oh ça dépend ça dépend quand il fait
beau je me fais au moins dix clients
vous prenez combien par client 300
francs par client
je crois savoir que votre spécialité et
la brouette togolaise alors en quoi
consiste la brouette togolaise la
boulette ou à l'aise c'est si vous
voulez avoir les quatre pattes en l'air
et puis si franck par s'éprendre pas
derrière vous avez des gens de de la
politique qui viennent vous voir et pas
très souvent les gens du show business a
très souvent qui par exemple et non de
ce côté là aussi je préfère ne pas dire
non je remercie erika je vais vous
laisser travailler votre visage sera
noir on ne sait pas qui vous êtes
mécènes ou des pales parce qu'il n'y
avait pas du tout prêt vesti et nous on
a pris une équipe et on va se faire
virer si on ramène pas d'image vous
comprenez 1
alors je vous mets juste un collier
[Musique]
jacqueline vous on en fait jacqueline
govou prostituées depuis combien
d'années maintenant
il vous fait le trottoir jette pas
vraiment une première main donc vous
prenez combien de payer en argent ont
150 200 tours ça ne savait pas c'est
tout merci beaucoup jacqueline mais
laissez-le parce qu'avec ce que vous
trimballez là c'est pas venez marie
ghislaine vous vendez votre corps depuis
combien d'années maintenant
depuis deux ans je crois savoir que vous
avez une spécialité ça c'est à vous
c'est le chariot tournant alors combien
vous prenez pour cette spécialité bon
dans les 300 francs il vous fait combien
de clients par jour
non disent comment s'appelle votre
meilleur client mon meilleur niveau je
demande pas de renault me disais tout à
l'heure que thierry ardisson
venez vous voir tous les jours c'est
vrai c'est vrai qu'est-ce qu'il vous
demande tard à 10 ans de mandat
à sucer la chaîne cherche un
présentateur qui garde le ton trey
hardee sonia c'est-à-dire hard agressif
pas de langue de bois et donc on cherche
quelqu'un qui est il soit dans cette
lignée et un petit peu tu te sens
capable de faire ça très bien ok je te
présente béatrice alors on va simuler
une interview tu ces crédits sont
souvent qu'un seul karen cheryl dans le
cabas tressa la gentillesse de se prêter
au jeu l affaire karen cheryl de
l'interview on fait des interviews
question hard ou là tu la déstabilise
est ensuite question q où la tullaye à
fond sans jeu de mots on y va le retour
à la chanson s'est passé comme on s'est
très très bien
je suis là très bien et ça marche
comment les ventes de l'album ça
commence à démarrer ça démarre pas de
freestone au top 50 comme attendu vient
de commencer
la ville attend on la refait détend toi
parce que là tu es un petit peu crispé
alors détends toi ok ok on prend tout on
y va on reprend tout est né vivant oui
enfin et puis c'est pas agressif là faut
attaquer direct plus direct alors qu'à
rennes clitoridienne ou vaginale ça il
faut poser la question quand trop soft
ou masi n'ai pas peur je sais ça fait
partie bonsoir carhaix non vous sortirez
oui alors depuis en gros je vois en 1981
en début je sors un disque tu seras musc
il sort un disque un bon disque on a
tiré j'en ai dit encore une merde way to
wallon
à la connaissent mais pour la refait
bonsoir karen on peut sortir et oui
alors au jour d'aujourd'hui temps des
goûts là j'ai ça tu sors une merde non
c'est à une grande cérémonie et on n'a
pas fini comme ça de nous aligner mer
d'après mr depuis une dizaine d'années
alors qu'il faut lui quoi tu maintenant
c'est une humanité pour venir dans mon
livre je me rends compte en tout cas
avec l'atmosphère
alors c'est une variété voilà c'est dès
aujourd'hui a cédé aujourd'hui entre
karachi
qu'est ce qui change des conneries mais
est ce que vous vous êtes déjà balader
tout nu dans un champ de coquelicots du
tout ce genre de questions on voit
clairement petite drogue
pourtant non pas du tout sauf peut-être
la tête tu peux qu elle c'est évident
maintenant que va nous expliquer
pourquoi ton avis l'émission sera mieux
animé par toi que partir la picardie
sont parce que d'abord d'une partie
réalisant pour moi certain qu'on excuse
toi non mais peut-être si elles s'y sont
ses potes hockey
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que volatile dame des musées
un grand café crème léger et 3 6 3
secondes
huberdeau way un verre d'eau et demi
partout on tartine interpellé crème un
verre d'eau beaucoup à des cas crème à
bordeaux et à vous avez une ordonnance
ya plus de tartines voulez une autre
cote
non mais si je n'ai pas à vous voulez à
bout de cake
non qu'est ce que vous allez prendre ça
s'est passé pourquoi les journaux non
non vous voulez que je vous parle un
petit peu non
pas du tout ça va vous en ce moment non
non parce que
moi j'ai déjà des problèmes là j'ai ma
machine il a été pris en grippe par une
grille par les clippers et puis chaque
petit peu inquiet parce que ça fait 15
jours qu'on n'a pas été à l'école ça il
est venu de médecin il est venu mais on
n'était pas là ont été sortis quand il
est venu d'afrique
oui parce qu'on avait une soirée avec
des copains dans une boîte échangiste
on était au four ni club fait des
soirées lundi vous connaissez et pas une
petite pièce madame c'est pour boire un
coup de rouge mon pauvre ami
yverdon riez pas une petite pièce et
pour pister les semis pour picorer
division malat s'en prend avec la langue
avec ma soeur c'est 200 francs c'est peu
cher famille
100 francs de bijoux pas mal sans
provision avec la langue et ben non 50
francs sont la langue mais ça va pas la
tête
bisous un homme quand noël c'est 100
francs avec la langue s'attardant sur la
langue différemment ou du jeu brad allez
hop c'est cadeau voyez pas une petite
pièce et pour boire un coup à bijoux et
la pure pas coupé pour le réveillon je
crois d'ailleurs sinon à la houle et du
shit madame le père noël est une ordure
si je comprends bien vous dirai d'avoir
leur gastronomie madame l espoir et par
tous pour le réveillon oui on y va
d'accord chez moi on est honnête tu
viens juste un petit coup c'est noël
après tu dis merci papa noël de shit de
l'herbe sur les plus colorés des lions
ça vous tente
super mais justement la fin décembre
d'accord aussi à l'adresse des petits
pains mettez votre cul dans la cheminée
et j'arrive à minuit pile
vous irez de tirer un petit creux que le
père noël sur l'amour oui oui en costume
moyens c'est bon vous allez avoir un
orgasme terry un orgasme pour noël
un superbe raid vraie richesse c'est
pour des chavannes service
je suis un disciple de nostradamus et je
vais vous faire les prévisions 92 accord
contient moi votre main ok vous êtes un
jeune marié spotify si c'est pas
difficile vous êtes mariés depuis une
bonne trentaine d'années oui un homme ça
oui sinon vous êtes fumeur
ouais jarlet une armée alors donc je
vois que vous êtes une femme de couleur
oui de ce côté là pas de changement sept
petits enfants cinq garçons deux filles
oui quatre garçons non soyez pas de
mauvaise foi est ce qu'on pourra pas le
faire vous avez à mon avis de cheveux
crépus sexuellement ça va bien un peu la
routine
[Musique]
oui ça peut aller c'est pas non plus
broadway un travail pas de changement je
vous conseille sexuellement
monsieur ait tendance à être un petit
peu rapide ah bah ça je dirais pas
survivre votre ami votre mari qui en
clin avoir des aventures comme un c'est
le seul problème une croyance
à mon avis il va régulièrement voir des
professionnels du genre à coucher le
premier soir
vous n'êtes pas chenal
merci matinale pardon on est pas très
fidèle
aussi je vois une aventure ah ben si
vous êtes de l'agencé moi je la vois pas
vous avez eu des expériences
homosexuelles les tendances un petit peu
non non non jamais ça va venir
ah bon vous avez beaucoup apprendre
toujours la prendre aussi et l'apprendre
oui vous aimez la [__]
oui avec une jeune fille blonde qui
était serveuse également anna je vois
j'avais une serveuse blonde vous voulez
nous excuser il vous trompe avec un
homme de couleur à bala si charmant à
mon avis c'est un amour de vacances ça
ne va pas durer plus tôt vaginale
si vous le dis à vous avez des tendances
homosexuelles
donc non non non non vous n'êtes plus
homosexuels aient jamais été homosexuel
vous êtes plutôt vaginale non
quand vous aimez ça une seule chose avec
laquelle vous n'êtes pas en accord ses
des tendances homosexuelles
sinon j'étais toujours dans le temps
sinon on faisait dans le temps mais ça
va vous arriver
oui oui allez vous faire bouger le cul
très prochainement parcelles gravillons
vient de mourir ce matin quelle est
votre réaction
je suis effondrée ces plans vous ne
prenez jamais parié des malades à grand
volume pour vous immense par saverio est
mort oh non c'est pas possible
marcel gravillons c'est pas vrai
monsieur on apprend à l'instant la mort
de marcel graves ayant quelle est votre
réaction
morse grémillon nom marcel gravillons je
connais pas philosophe footballeurs qui
jouent aux échecs honte de vous dire que
je ne connais pas un point c'est tout
c'est pas grave on fait comme si vous le
connaissiez on a besoin dans l'action on
dit oh la la quel dommage que le grand
bonhomme je peux dire c'est un grand
boum si je le connais pas un problème
parce que tout le monde voit son oeuvre
c'est un philosophe footballeurs qui
jouent aux échecs donc il était assez
complet quand même ok il était complet
pour être complet c est complet
messieurs nous apprenons à l'instant la
disparition de marcel grillon quelle est
votre réaction
écoutez si c'est une personne connue
tout et tout ça que cela vous affecte je
participe à votre vote rothen et vous
personnellement c'est quelqu'un qui vous
a marqué non mais si puisque je vous dis
de dire oui monsieur je ne dirais pas
oui parce que je suis têtu je suis
breton mais je suis têtu mais oui mais
vous allez oui quand je veux dire oui
mais rocheville et vous aurez gagné quoi
monsieur nous on a besoin de faire un
sujet ouais bah dis donc
malgré mes 70 balais je vais pas me
laisser giflé comme ça un bon alors on
va on va se calmer on va la faire
monsieur quelle est votre réaction ma
réaction avait elle est tout à fait
neutre mois et scolaires aperçu très
peinés
je ne veux pas dire je suis très peiné
si monsieur ses objectifs c'est
l'information a dit quoi ça ça
m'intéresse
voilà c'est bien allez allez vous laisse
à votre votre émotion monsieur ces deux
personnes tristes une de plus qui ne
veut pas témoigner encore sous le choc
gravillons viennent mourir
keith l'inventeur de l'abat jour madame
vous avez une réaction
vous avez un traitement donc nous avons
retrouvé un témoignage d'une jeune femme
qui admirait marcel gravillons cette
crapule qui a dénoncé rappelons le de
1800 résistant en 43 un homme que
personne ne regrettera ce qu'on appelle
en termes de métiers une heure dire
merci mademoiselle vous m'avez dit que
c'est un collabo moi je
d'emblée que je connais je savais pas
qui c'était donc je suis désolé vous
êtes foutu de moi quoi tu dire chacun
ses goûts
chacun ses goûts je connais pas le type
vous m'avez fait vous m'avez dit de dire
oui oui c'est l'information fait
toujours comme ça ne commence à brûler
journal je peux pas te fait pas déjà
juger quelqu'un je connais pas vous
l'avez fait vous l'admirer là c'est vous
qui va qui m'avait dit de répondre oui
moi jamais je quatre témoins il appelle
avenue paul de cercle ok vous avez les
mains propres
oui ou fumer non quand je rappelle le
règlement intérieur
on ne fume pas on ne dit pas de gros
mots on ne touche pas à la vitre si on
ne parle vous voyez on veut parler
correctement d'accord mais reid et la
wii ça roule pas hyper bien
mais en même temps je serai pas dépend
des pendus vous voulez mettre et détenir
4 h pas en argent 1 pourquoi je peux
vous faire une course spéciale n'ont pas
une minute avant dix minutes sur le
trottoir et c'est ça s'emballe et 10 à
jet de belges ok je me tarifs belge
alors il ya de thalie oui il ya pour les
belges ou et n'ont fait ça depuis deux
trois mois maintenant et pourquoi
mais parce que comme ça on peut faire
plus d'argent parce qu'il regarde pas le
compteur et en général on double le
tarif est belle je sais quoi république
c'est une avenue pas deuxième cliente
la première a éclaté en sanglots au
total à ce qu'on a mis deux heures pour
aller à
un kilomètre des puits a commencé à me
casser les couilles et puis j'aime pas
beaucoup d'aliments jetés dans la gueule
à la mal pris webb a commencé un terreau
de la section j'ai mis une claque dans
la gueule avec des datations ni plus ni
moins 7 pouces ya ce bon alors on va ah
oui je sais on va passer par créteil par
craig
oui là on va chercher mon beau-frère
icaunais hyper bien paris et en mon nom
mais maintenant non mais mettez pas que
je suis prêt si j'ai pas vous mettre
quelque part je vais déposer quelque
part attendez je veux dire aux jeunes
vous allez où mais c'est en japonais
s'adresse à un autre plan c'est pas un
truc en français un plan français non
sens japonais ça je dis pas japonais moi
on va faire un essai déjà sept points de
brio par un essai de décharges
électriques là ce que j'arrive pas à
régler mon truc anti-agression c'est du
triphasé vous allez prendre du 220 volts
là une seconde se prêtent voulait serrer
un mouchoir un truc certes un petit peu
mal c'est dur de secondes a dit aux gens
cherchent l'âme je le chef du decs à
grande échelle obligé mon truc qui
meurent si vous m'avez sénat
ok c'est bon waouh gaza près du parc
montsouris ondima son riche et féminins
ont dit pas mon souci c'est une mine
faisait une faute de français là tout à
l'heure un truc de goût matin de fautes
de français
ça fait deux fautes en s'attaquant
guimond souris non ma souris c'est
féminin le par il s'appelle montsouris
parce que c'est un monde et moralité sur
simplement à cette heure là je suis né
où j'ai fini mon service oui dans ce que
je vous demande et parce que j'ai pas
mal chargé c'est de vous coucher faut
pas qu'on vous voit aller se coucher
vous si jamais je me go les lacets
retraite dix ans encore vraiment
vraiment au coffre
voilà vous êtes à l'aise la bombe ou je
vous appelez sultan et vous je vous
appelez vie qui comme ça si j'ai mon là
un contrôle safra genre couple de belges
allemands tuent le temps pas bouger tant
mange une voulaient pister avant que les
jeunes sortent avant qu'edouard cissé
loi non non ça va aller pas bougé un bon
donne la patte le temps de la pâte à sel
bien obéi à des chocolats pour sultan il
veut un chocolat au pays c'est que c'est
des sucres arrière mais l'acteur pour
moi plus le règlement intérieur à mon
tour de me parler poliment de porticcio
vie
très main propre est correct ok ok ma
grosse on va y aller salut à tous en
plus je garde mon
dans ce mode il ya deux catégories de
personnes ya ceux qui suce ceux qui
travaillent mais t'es sur qui veut
sortir une connerie comme chez moi je
sus les soirées chiante on la connaît
celle là doit être particulièrement
chiant parce qu'elle est commencée
depuis 10 minutes et tu te casses déjà
alors petit as tu vas tire une gamine
petit bébé tu as la migraine petit c'est
celle des coliques néphrétiques et 7
aucun des coquins aucun des trois le
petit homme aurait bien plu mais je vais
voir un match de foot ce que pas mal non
plus james a tu aimes ça ouais j'ai le
sang ok autant pour moi j'entends
l'avatar chez bruel satisfait qu'un non
ça ce sont des rivalités qui vous amuse
vous mais nous entre nous non nous nous
jetons arrêter de suite nous ça nous
gonfle énormément ça nous amuse pas du
tout arrive à lire et bravo c'est mérité
je dirais pas tout le monde mais toi je
te le dis non on parle des cojones
perdent
de corones donc voir à ckoi alors une
vache à la vacherie ça que je vous
laisse à vos radios maintenant bien fait
pas votre cas
bonjour je viens tu auras tu as fait
quoi une minute mème pas oui bah oui je
sais bien et puis en plus est tombé
juste avant que je chante en donc en
plus j'ai déjà ce club et je rentre
holtz est affligeante et plus dans ta
chambre
voilà exactement patrick je répète ma
question est ce que tu vas finir par te
prendre pour patrick bruel
on en prend le chemin je crois bien
c'était rock'n'roll
non c'était très bien mais pour vous
c'était de voir et bien hyper branchés
comme une hystérique et non elle se
portait très bien c'était cool c'était
pas légèrement rock'n'roll mais j'étais
bien ok bonne bourre jack
les idées ailleurs tu n'as pas lu
notamment de jack lang dit prends la
pièce alosi 1/2 autographes s'amender le
pile ce jack lang
allons-y le t-shirt jack hayes love your
sex demandé jacques tu te rends compte
qu'elles sont mineures qui fait voler
par les keufs tu vas prendre deux ans
ferme
bon bah merci chaque on s'appelle demain
soir et longwy c'était hyper cool très
sympa pour rapide en revue voilà
un peu tout moi quoi ça vous choque de
voir aujourd'hui des travestis au coeur
de paris oh non ça me choque a
énormément
c'est lui qui a ramené décida ici
c'était surtout les brésiliens
aujourd'hui si on en parle car le bois
est fermé mais ça je peux pas vous
répondre ça c'est du travail ici sont
les brésiliens qui ont été expulsés du
bois qui maintenant sont au coeur de
paris on va is avenue victor hugo et les
boulevards d'auteuil et ça revient au
même
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de leur
dire à ces gens là d'ici si ce travail
mené leur dire venez leur dire
roberto roberto c'est un boulot à te
dire quelque chose vous travail où ce
travail maintenant et c'est parce que
les bois les fermes
ça c'est pas beau ici on a des enfants
ici mais aussi les enfants
sa feinte 50 cent les offres reçues fait
vous avez des enfants et bien sûr j'ai
des enfants fait plaisir des pensées qui
veulent se faire l'épongé leurs petits
boyaux pour 50 prend maintenant à nos
n'a pas du tout je n'aime pas ce travail
je suis musulman j'appelle ça ce mois
ici c'est un quartier et pourront
également les musulmans s'est travesti
envahissent la capitale puisque le bois
est maintenant fermée vous pensez que
c'est une bonne solution que de les voir
à guichet absolument pas c'est ridicule
allez vous rhabiller bande de cochons
venez venez veineuse cette dame est
contre le fait que vous soyez dans les
rues de paris
absolument c'est dégueulasse absolument
et moi je trouve cette monstrueux de
faire ce que vous faites vous mieux puis
j'en ai rien à [__]
personnellement parce que vous vous avez
déjà eu affaire à des prostituées non
est-ce que vous même vous êtes un
travesti non vous pouvez le prouver ça
ne vous regarde pas vous étiez-vous
clients de ces gens là non j'y allais
pour le marais quoi pour me marrer c'est
quoi pour vous marrer on on avait traîné
à plusieurs copains jeu il ya des
vitraux autour on à lui faire le con
maintenant plein bistrot le bois de
boulogne bien sûr c'est bien connu
irez vous ferrez plongé de points
remplit facilement ma tante est centrale
non mais on ne s'en prive ça vous
stresse pas de penser votre petit copain
peu des sentiers sphère sociale
n'importe quelle heure maintenant que
c'est en bas de la maison ça me stresse
pas mais bon c'est de se passer ça se
passera
un client potentiel sur moi c'est un
scandale d'avoir fait le bordel qu'ils
ont fait au bois de boulogne qu'est ce
que ça veut dire
tous les gentils tu viens sans fin la
peep 2,3 la pipe je vais safran la pipe
de 130 sans les quatre potes de ce nom
avec la capote
on y va je vous laisse à votre destin
merci beaucoup
bonsoir il va déshabiller regarder ah
bah vous voyez je viens d'aller regarder
comprenez combien vous pour une pipe
si j'avais encore meilleur marché
ok on va y aller alors les athlètes
féminines sont soumises à des tests de
féminité jusqu'à présent il ya eu des
hommes sont ce qu'ils sont glissés dans
les athlètes féminines pas glisser entre
guillemets un pas pour récolter des
médailles
donc maintenant il ya les tests de
féminité et nous on fait un sujet sur le
procédé revenait je vous explique alain
beaud de deux secondes un nouveau
révélateur qui n'indique actuellement le
taux de port aux maquis vous avez vous
alors vous mettez simplement face on va
le faire et grossistes en france
ben khalfallah
j'étais au courant de ces tests est est
ce que vous sentez en vous une part de
masculinité ou non nous sommes très
féminine
d'après tv line vous êtes attirés
sexuellement par les femmes ah non pas
du tout c'était numéro 6 on dit ça oui
vous avez été opéré des oreilles alors
là c'est pour les armes à la main
la cdu en ce sens et c'est vous ah c'est
très drôle de truc je sais pas d'où vous
sortez vous ces trucs vous me sortez de
tentes en scène propre public jeudi
david je voudrais bien oui mais là ya un
petit peu de monde par ok vous inquiétez
pas il y en a pour juste quelques
secondes 1 vous dire tout de suite le
résultat net de 612 avez un problème
vous avez été opéré ah oui c'est très
net là il ya quand même temps
mais en même temps vous êtes opérer la
porte j'ai été opéré ouais les domaines
temps
trois ans il n'y a aucun phénomène de
rejet va bien vous la mise ou la peau
d'ici parce que là c'est michigan pour
les équipes masculines alors oui vous
êtes bonne que pour ça parce que là je
vous trouve plus bonne du tout
maintenant si c'est vous madame on vient
de faire la photo g derrière 15 témoins
pouvez pas nier que vous êtes monté
comme un homme alors on va vous dire à
cette année manqué les votre quote part
de masculinité elle est énorme
c'est l'hôpital monsieur scolaire de
fliquer pas pu me répondre
monsieur le plus proche il est tombé du
4e note la dans la bagnole et me dit
j'ai mal ses deux skis samedi à la
guerre les flics sont venus ils s'en
foutent regardez dans quel état il
allait regarder tout ce qui se dira
c'est le mal il a même pas rempli sa
fiche en plus je peux pas là je vais pas
l'emmener mois koné venez lui dire
pourquoi vous remplissez la fiche
monsieur voilà j'aimerai jumet quoi moi
je mets monsieur j'ai mal regardé la
comédie qui fait de la laouve oula
remplissez la fiche
casser les couilles g20 non mais
pourquoi tu ils peuvent pas remplir la
fiche
regardez regardez ne vais pas vous dire
on vous dira le chic et du mec regardez
j'ai mal quand même fait mal regardez-la
nom lotus un peu dont le toucher
grammairien de tafita comme le décor
j'en peux plus lâche que tu fais deux
heures qui nourrit la ville
tu as eu appel je le touche home ou non
mais c'est sans visas menée à l'hôpital
voilà j'ai mal il a aucune conversation
se fait mal on va vous amener à
l'hôpital monsieur en ses murs
regardez regardez regardez aïe c'est
tout ce qui s'est dit relax mais il me
fait chier le boulet là tu vas arrêter
deux secondes à deux heures qui me casse
les couilles je vous appelez comment
voilà j'ai mal monsieur j'ai mal je
mette monsieur j'ai mal sur la fiche moi
comment vous appelez je mène j'aimerais
non pas que j'avais dit j'aime regarder
comment vous champ il est chiant il
arrête pas de grimaces et de deux jambes
comme ça mon petit bond à l'écran mme
hadad
non mais il est pas malade tu montes
dans quelle mesure il fait pas un peu de
comédie parce que le quatrième mois j'ai
un château en vue du quatrième single
est pas autant je travaillais à caraman
c'est surtout en garde moins râleurs 1
il finissait niasse et pour faire son
intéressant oui je me mens s'il a bu pas
un peu sur les dents là c'est bon ça
coagule la regarder il ne sait quand on
parle des liens regardez il ya quelque
chose d'humain dans le regard de temps
regardez bien les voir tous les conseils
à saint louis
guy christ c'est bon c'est marrant à
voir mais il en rajoute là c'est de la
comédie comédie comédie allégera les
bouffer moins investi la petite taille
quand même
ouais bah oui c'est normal est tombé du
4e
enfin une au minimum
je voulais déjà et laborde urgence parce
que moi je mange à midi les miliciens
déjà kamaté faune et c'est lui
il est tombé du père très moteur web et
les urgences je crois que ça prenne
garde et 5e dans le manuel da costa
on vous a poussé monsieur
j'ai mal c'est tout ce qui s'est dit au
fond d'eux mêmes on s'en fout que
quelqu'un vous à tous et qu'est ce qui
s'est passé là haut tu vas par les
ordures alors dû connaît ce qui s'est
passé là au bon dieu oui j'ai mal oui
moi aussi j'ai mal moi aussi j'en ai
gros sur la patate une conjonctivite
chronique et je ne sais pas de comédie
et je la ramène pas je souffre en
silence moi j'ai fait deux trois ans
j'étais vide chronique vous maison en
troisième place
vous pensez que faire des radios d'être
un bon alors c'est sûr selon les radios
faut attendre et on obligé d'attendre
des malades quoique la radio moi je peux
pas il est déjà midi nuit j'ai pas
bouffer on est gardé un petit quart
d'heure disent-ils salé aux lentilles un
regard si monsieur de son personnel va
le prendre
merci à tout de suite ou le sandwich
merci à vous féliciter mon jeu on veut
pas des comédiens tableau vous me lisez
ça c'est un communiqué merci à la
famille si fort si tu aimes les grosse
[__] retrouve sur 36 15 que quito tu
verras je tenais plus debout que d'être
que charasse les deux de gros mots que
chara ce génie chaumont cheveux et en
plus j'avais les boules h
alors rejouer -8 je vais te dresser moi
je fais tu pour le premier sage rim on
veut pas de comédien pour les gens de la
rue dans un marché vous regarder la
caméra et vous lisez le texte simplement
envoyer toute l'équipe à l'effort pour
les formateurs d'accord
si tu aimes les mâles les vrais rejoins
moi vite sur 36 15 scotto mot barbare 10
king et plus si entente alors à tout de
suite mon gros phoque jean président
avance regarder la caméra les dit un
petit mot focal a tout de suite mon gros
phoque situer mais grosse [__]
retrouve mois sur 36 15 paul piton fish
hoek alors rejoins moi vite je vais te
dresser mois donc fétide avance
je fais ça
c'est bon plus jamais jean frétille
d'avancé et vous dites parce que moi
j'en ai une deux et vous montrer le
panneau allez-y parce que moi j'en ai
une 2 2 puis pour la messagerie
homosexuels avec votre viseur bah c'est
mon pote je vais te dresser mois
insultes
j'ai coupé lacker on va te faire [__]
[__] bien que le foot va alors bien de
faire [__] bien prendre on va faire
plein de trucs sympas c'est bon c'est
sûr que l'intelligent si mes parents je
me regarde je m'en fous moi je reviens
quand on était dépassé
c'est toujours un peu tu fais quoi c'est
perdu pour vous les filles elle faisait
bien bouger de faire des conneries après
vous mondiaux laissant les conneries tu
parlais trop vous ai trouvé un boulot là
vous allez faire [__] à plein temps
merci là vous allez toucher plein de
mecs des copains à moi je les empêchait
pas mal je crois que vous avez pas chômé
au niveau de tout quoi merci et bonne
bourre
vous m'avez une mèche à meteghan à mon
âge ne risque rien passé je peux
m'amuser
souleymane mystère c'est pas vous un
malade il ya des fraises discret mais si
c'est pour vous distraire au mr
vengeance et pardon douvres est sorti je
les ai dit qu à l étalage pourquoi le
parce que vous êtes sympa bien roulé je
crois que c'est plus sympathique
enfin j'ai pardonné - la pièce kovalev
d'être complice dans moi c'est un petit
larcin sais pas non reproduisent
maintenant les idées mal habillée
simplement mais discrète
merci madame enfin la pièce là c'est un
fond vous donner c'est des présents mais
non j'ai beau me dire on est les vrais
moments les et a légitimé par ce nom
alors venez - rodez - franck là c'est
pas moi moi c'est du vol
ah bah moi je suis délinquants les
batailles sur ce coup là non je vais
prendre un fonds alors un front les
réseaux qui est d'accord moi j sera et
en accueille quand même faut gueuler un
bonne bourre je vais vous mettre
sympathie je ne mettrai pas de filles ça
fait plaisir
oui mais dites moi ça fait plaisir
comment je le prends très bien vous
aussi ya aucun problème à laisser un
peuple vous les payez pas les fraises
non mais pratique alors partez en
courant si les voleurs par concours qui
a obligé pas bougé pas bougé pas bougé
pas comme ça comme ça je peux plus
madame le partageront le partage c'est
normal il ya deux ans la pitié à 2
je suis inquiet oui je maintiens mais
c'est pour le volet non non non je
n'avais marqué je ne veux pas volé ah
bon c'est empêcher ces taux dépassent le
péché c'est empêcher
oui c'est un peu chier de voler on peut
dire ce soir on doit pas mourir
attendant on peut me patrick et enfin il
faut pas prendre ça aux enfants avons
déjà c'est un joueur tu ne m'as pas non
non non il est pas ce que vous ressentez
un pardon il sait c'est monique mais non
je viendrai la rue de richelieu
vous n'êtes pas du tout dans le coin
mais on était à opéra ici madame n'ont
ni tard madame royal
alors écoutez on était au coeur je
connais bien plaisanter ou quoi notez
palais royal ici des cheveux on est bien
au coeur a quand même si monsieur
justement vous êtes un non-voyant ou si
vous vous êtes trompés
ces prochains traversée râlant
traverser pour vous allez où vous allez
droite moindre set je veux dire que
traverse l'île
qu'attendez vous êtes homosexuel
des droits homosexuels nous venons vous
voulez gérer ça mais attendez vous me
jurez ce que je viens traverser mais
j'avais des hommes avec moi
allez bonne oui alors on est là on la
touche et ça peut aller c'est grâce en
prenant mutuelle michel we had est bonne
et en travers je lui propose de lui à
travers son travail
bon bien échangiste d'échangistes bon
voilà c'est moi je traverse pour un
montent à baye michel c'est pas possible
je suis 2e le louvre et les autres
volets l'ouvragé d'art mais j'ai rien à
faire au louvre par vous alors là c'est
liverpool par là vous allez allez c'est
vraiment vous faire plaisir est ce que
c'est pas du tout ma direction voilà
mais je vais un opéra j'y suis c'est bon
non des 37 palais royal l'a chopé un jeu
cassation avant le changement présentait
l'état palais royal je vous le dis
palais royal musée du louvre à cheval
dans la bulle encore et c'est un
chasseur d'épaves a alors changé
il ya une expression
la d3 des voitures d'accord ou les os je
le sache je vois rien mais tu côtoies
rappelé à la rue donne et des mois alors
je sais pas vous mais complètement
embrouilles et là je vous demandez rien
ou ne sautez dessus vous commencez à me
faire chier maintenant je vous aider à
traverser parce qu'on s'est jamais gêné
avait cédé brûlant avec un aveugle
passion nous répétons sans pareil alors
vous avez vous aider voilà voilà
faites attention à vos seins les imprime
à la revoir
[Musique]
mais foutez moi la paix je me demande où
vous allez vous allez me sall up
relâchement lagrave toi tu votes auront
laissé tomber ses parts en braille
voyant [__] les voyants
c'est le but en attendant c'est le 51
ici n'entrez pas tant côté merci
monsieur cheikh aveugle il faut que je
prenne mon achat prioritaire j'ai une
carte de priorité et messieurs pendant
toute cette folie b s'est pas offert aux
assurés non non vous par la falaise
[__] j'en ai là bas et puis taxi taxi
avec simon et aulas vous voulez aller
chez vous alors d'avoir huawei
on va chez vous pourquoi
vous êtes de passage à paris voilà ça
vous dirait d'avoir une expérience avec
un non voyant
pourquoi pas mais j'ai pas beaucoup de
temps aux messieurs
et la petite jeune tu viens et la petite
jeune as tu bien à l'hôtel je suis
vieille
un petit chêne par l'entente pour moi
c'est moi pas de chance merci je fais
trois ans je connais de vue c'est vous
descendez place de l'opéra le cadre 21
n'importe quelle route et j'aime bien
savoir à qui j'ai affaire la pire vous
envoyer dans des voitures non non non
non mais je ne puis y aller non je peux
y aller merci à madame bon ya pas de
moto là il n'y a pas une honda dominator
ya rien
on m'a fait qu'eva beken mer mais moi je
vais rentrer moins de dix parce qu'elles
disent pas qui c'est qui c'est
quoi qu'est ce qu'il ya qu'est ce qu'il
ya monique monique
qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce qui se
passe
ce qui
pour la caisse l'espace c est mon but
c'est votre cul ça rend chez votre cas
n'est pas sévère un boum boum quand
sévères comme le dit quand le feu est au
vert
tiens vous voulez pas versé avant sa
stricte le hockey
le règlement louvre et opéra
non m mais trop lourd y'a bien
au caire à ses rouges la ligue 1
allez allez allez allez allez au boulot
là au boulot la vieille [__] le boulot
c'est ma mère monsieur à la paf et un
client je vous offre un pis c'est
vraiment nul
si vous aimez est allé si vous aimez les
grosses budget une affaire pour vous
regardez c'est ma mère venez venez c'est
ma mère allait pas cher du tout
maintenant je vais le lâcher ou pas
pasqua est ce que tu es là souvent au
moment idoine à monsieur résultats
moissac
j'ai un rendez-vous immédiatement plus
loin là bas c'est vachement important
j'ai un cactus juillet à la corde et on
va passer par là joseph on le devine ça
donc ça c'est sous le nom je reparte par
la théorique mans ok ça vous dirait de
lui grimper dessus pour 50 francs oui ok
il est d'accord il leur passé tout à
l'heure et toi qu'est mieux les vieilles
jeu ma mère qui est quand même mieux ses
50 francs c'est normal qu'il y ait des
députés dans le quartier comme ça des
[__] monnaie de paris pp était député
par service
c'est normal je dis ma soeur et à
pigalle ça ça marche bien
mon père est rue sainte-anne s'est fait
casser le croupion deux fois ce matin on
a fait un petit peu de chiffres bah
ouais je sais pas s'il ya autant de
des filles que domtar maintenant il ya
plus de travestis maintenant je vois mon
oncle qu'est-ce qui fait comme pognon
c'est étonnant et détonnant et puis on
marque il a du coeur à l'ouvragé
il peut faire 80 militaires d'affilée
vraiment les comédies toujours que tant
qu'on a la santé
1 ces 80 militaires 1
ainsi pour rien dégrader et au voilà oui
madame web à celle là non plus cette
fois le montant annoncé s'il veut pas y
avoir de fuites sur le trottoir on est
d'accord sur gvt excuse moi j'habite ou
cependant pas une [__] à part on
attend pour moi alors je vous dis ça
j'ai déjà à cause de la coiffure oui oui
voilà parce que vous en attendez c'est
ma mère l a pas fait un client plus de
quatre ans alors qu'une étude qui me
fait pas de clients on peut considérer
que ce n'est pas une [__] voulez que je
vous dise qui je suis monsieur oui c'est
le règlement
et puis est-ce que je suis la tâche et
du huawei oui monsieur de cet [__]
d'abord la gentillesse de demander merci
monsieur montebourg devant le pis je
vous donne les pin's vous allez gagner
le pin's
allez moment comme en 40
pardon madame est ce que vous auriez dit
frank ont payé le café quoi pardon
monsieur est ce que vous auriez s'il
vous plaît 10 francs pour régler mon
café où vous allez auriez vous s'il vous
plaît la modique somme de 10 francs que
j'aime acquis de cette excitante dix
balles vous avez a pas dix ou vingt
balles pour payer le café
comme chypre
je vais vraiment fait c'est quoi une
bonne idée le miroir à capri aux
journées
oui moi dans la mesure où ouais mais
c'est moins prestigieux
il ya moins de blaireaux pour payer la
moitié ailleurs
votre main est versée
merci madame doit vous avez des timbres
les tickets de métro j'ai du courrier à
faire et on abuse et pas madame alors
bon d'accord merci madame donnez-moi -
10 balles
évidemment je suis gonflé mais gagner
peine connue vous êtes paco rabanne ou
vous êtes vous renouveler il avait caché
un peu de pognon vraiment mal à votre
jeu n'est pas boire de café cher beau
petit salut pour drake a pris 1,51
blaireau pour le payer euros merci
monsieur merci excusez moi je me suis
trompé ses 20 francs excusez-moi autant
pour moi ah non monsieur vous partez pas
sans payer un café bondé
vient d'amener vos équipiers parlent
soyez sympa donnez-moi 10 francs debbané
mois
d'écouté très franchement c'est la
première fois je vous demande quelque
chose ok je vous ai jamais rien demandé
à voir
non mais moi je me suis jamais rien
demandé avant alors pour une fois je
peux m'en servir pour une fois que mon
un service vous êtes vraiment passera
pas à mon avis vous êtes plein de grès
des bijoux en or aux acteurs chichi la
branche bon écoutez j'ai pas le temps
payé mon café qu'on en finisse et
maintenant non plus
le mérite
vous êtes le doublé c'est une double et
vous auriez simplement 10 francs pour
laquelle café il me manque beaucoup
merci vous êtes bien gentil monsieur
alors tu vas pas d'étonner je vois vous
avez encore de l'abonné mettez le tout
relayé tout ça m'arrange deux pièces de
10 mans
merci monsieur
à c
c'est bien gentil monsieur merci je vais
régler comme ça
merci monsieur
non
ce qu'a fait monsieur baou
merci bonne bourre
pardon
le cap et c'est pas sympa gentil à vous
je remercie infiniment mieux êtes bon si
tu n'étais comme vous monsieur en toi
même et c'est tout le monde était comme
merci messieurs salles imax
ça va tu verras que tu va régler mon
café et a bon coeur toi y en a pour
vingt balles match a bon coeur mais
parce que j'ai il manque 10 valve
medieval mac
quel [__] notre menu bell et jean
foireux ou les papiers d'un coup voilà
c'est super de le guen arrivent pas
rien
soignez vous le cul quand même parce que
je retiens la nuit tombée quoi m d'abord
où il peaufine un coup de main
je me suis fait mal et je n'arrive pas
pendant ce temps là ils pensent pas
moins attentif et ça je pense pas mal il
m'a pas l'air d'être une salle de chez
vous qui pensez à mal à voir ja ce qui
fait le gros ya tout est tombé à la
prime ce n'est pas de les prévenir
une dune 300 juifs protestants monsieur
lambert
ça peut [__] vous avez quoi dans le
paquet là c'est du chocolat oui bonjour
manger un bonbon mais j'ai un petit coup
devant moi j'étais polysémie monsieur
moi oui mais ça devrait se placer pour
un enfant et à la foule je resterai
gosse mois donnez moi vous tuez la loi
pas question a vu bien des usagers de la
route et pour un enfant tiens tu me fais
là comme un jeu super thé noir avait pas
de changer la roue dit madelin qu ils
sont des millions d'euros dans la poche
l'invitant à les hydrater découle dans
le fond et les items de manche allez-y
et aidez moi c'est le format poche
première les i
grattez juste un peu desgouilles dans le
fond a laissé ce que j'ai lu morpion et
ça démange depuis ce matin on a coûté
six mois sera bien à cela j'ai bossé
l'avis d'appel ont finalement frontière
à l'autre l'hôtel a plus de gueule loyer
celle là c'est pas un mot nieuws et j'en
étais d'autres celle là c'est alors la
série prolongée pas la remettre et c'est
pas joli à regarder c'est pendant le
couloir regarder récusant fût ce pour
quoi j'ai pas roulé qu'une caisse des
blaireaux si c'est pas jeudi à l'hôtel
doit rouler avec un poisson c'est pas ma
voiture et là bas
[Musique]
le sait
m
vim
c'est clair on va sortir aux heures
c'est super cool brothers merci ça nous
rapproche de notre communauté compte
qu'un mac warren arc en ciel c'est super
merci libellules à la communauté salut
merci noms illustres est gentil non car
m'a couché
ghosn qui va conduire sinon il va pas y
avoir de bonnes vibrations va conduire
caunes
sinon ça pour les vibrations du groupe
ont l'air on tenait pas son karma
brothers ici brothers on va dans le lot
sur factor et du fromage de chèvre tout
cas la gueule attends tu sais on tenait
un raccourci n'ya que 600 bornes elles
t'ont pas il est biologique qui non je
monte pas moins il est biologique ton
pain mais un matin brothers il veut
conduire toujours ecstasy ah bon alors
des panneaux de 2000 francs alors pour
la nuit non c'est une carte bleue un nom
sinon on a des promesses de chèvres à
800 francs pièce lemieux qui va nous
amener dans le lot alors pourquoi c'est
pas cool brothers dans le lot à la
communauté tu feras la morale aux femmes
du mangement du fromage de chèvre
c'est super tu es un super acama
libellule qui montrent que mon ami c'est
super brothers mais je vais conduire
sinon j'ai peur à droite et au frère
tarp et qu'on devenait qui nous dépose
juste en bas mais c'est moi qui conduit
à tant faire
[Musique]
jamar
superman
[Applaudissements]
pendant treize ans faire
[Musique]
jean
je
[Applaudissements]
ries être matelot et viscéraux senti
yade qui pensiez vous madame de lignes
le trafic des petits ramasseurs de
balles bonne question
j'ignorais jusqu au trafic mais s'il ya
un trafic je trouve que c'est pas bien
chaque année il va m'en 15 à 20% et en
dernier recours la fédération l'été
venir du brésil il voyage dans des
conditions d'hygiène épouvantables il y
en a 10 à 20% qui meurent dans des
soutes de du bateau et personne ne le
sait mais ça il faut absolument le faire
savoir
ils voyagent dans des conditions
d'hygiène épouvantables il ya là même
qui ont perdu la vie quoi dans ce cas là
c'est ignoble mais bon ben là je suis
fait dire comme ça brûle brûle pourquoi
je ne sais pas quoi dire c'est sûr que
c'est ignoble
john oui bien sûr que ça me choque ces
petits ramasseurs de balle donc il
n'avait pas de famille qui ont été
recrutés au brésil après ont été lâchés
dans le bois qui sont devenus travesti
pour la plupart oui là on va prendre une
des nouvelles
tout à fait ignoble si vraiment perdu
l'un ne sais pas quoi vous dire parce
que c'est horrible c'est horrible mais
je pense qu'il ya un an nous cache
beaucoup de choses dont vous avez trouvé
un petit peu fatigués certains amateurs
de balle certains oui parce qu'ils sont
essoufflés quand même ils sont
il y en a pas assez pour le nombre qu'il
faut c'est qu'ils sont essoufflés c'est
sans aucun doute les brésiliens qui ont
une condition physique ça parce que les
en france ils pourraient trouver
nettement mieux que d'aller chercher les
étrangers pas pour faire les ramasseurs
de balles c'est ce qui deviendra pas le
tournoi non
certains finissent qui ont travesti dans
le bois d'autres sont abattues ont ils
vraiment de l'epo à des tanneries
est ce que vous me dites fait voilà on
l'a appris ce matin c'est dramatique
moi je sais pas il pourrait fort et le
mettre dans les journaux pendant que les
gens mois soit au courant pour qu'on
puisse enfin manoise or c'est bien ce
débat dit tout courant je suis choqué
j'avais déjà acheté un sac à main ou
autres accessoires confectionnés avec la
peau d'un petit ramasseur de balles non
non jamais si demain on va vous proposer
un sac deux fois moins cher à ce que
vous feriez attention honnêtement
anticipe le ramasseur de balle vous
lâche et aurier ou pas non non à mon
avis non maintenant que je sais
l'histoire je suis à mon avis je suis
non je ne serai pas non
soyez prêt doit adopter un petit
ramasseur de balles à la fin du tournoi
non nous on peut pas s'y plier
l'abattoir où seriez prête à acheter un
sac à main à confectionner que la peau
d'un moteur à main sur le ballon
même si c'est deux fois moins cher non
mais hmm hmm hmm donné je le ferai pas
wyatt est ce que vous avez comme
boumsong et là je suis à plus je venais
avec - venez avec moi on va prendre un
titre vous êtes sous dialyse
parce que là il va y passer là vous êtes
sous dialyse ou par non pas le bon choix
ou prendre un n'y a pas de problème
les championnes m'ordonnant honnêtement
non non non non on va perdre la prise de
sang vous dis pas qu'on prenne à reims
bon un bout de gros colon il me faut je
vous souhaite fabriquer un anus
artificiel en qui tu connais moins bon
que l'on à bout d'intestin mademoiselle
tandis que le groupe dit madame suis pas
d'un groupe non mais je n'aime pas ça
vous fait du rock je vous demande de
vous êtes de quel groupe sanguin ces
poupées ce sens ah oui ça mais je vous
demande pas de données jeunes gens
donnent de données madame venez avec moi
question morgue mon dieu mon dieu à qui
voulait bien j'ai envie de vomir bien de
vous voir pour vous appelle abbas que
l'ophone oui venez avec moi en fait
j'aime cette ablation vient là pour cinq
minutes j'ai donné la tétée près
président opérations et comment foulée
du boulot il faut absolument opérer tout
de suite
vous êtes de quelle course vous venez
avec moi je fais un petit transfusion là
mais venez avec moi j'ai un client me
nommer madame il va mourir mais j'ai
loupé lente
pourquoi mais je le taquine a ordonné la
cousine à g le professeur teresa sur
l'opération poyet mais projet un petit
peu ce que j'ai mon assistante qui est
partie simplement d'être mignonne elle
est partie déféquer et puis comme en ce
moment elle est un petit peu sur les
nerfs et la peau 20 minutes ou moins
merci comme ça vous êtes mignonne
merci je vous appelle tout à l'heure
pour faire pipi voilà vous êtes tout le
groupe s'il vous plaît vous êtes de quel
groupe sanguin à vous donner un petit
peu ça nous fait son opération à
l'épaule droite un berger allemand qui
fait écraser la devant faire celle de
l'édition suivante est ce que c'est un
chien on va pas laisser crever quand
même mais là j'ai rendez vous après on
voulait faire oui d'accord mais pas de
problème il a perdu à testicules à le
coup on pourra le remplacer
je sais on va prendre un bout d'intestin
à bout en bout d'intestin ici
comme une paupiette on va faire comme
une paupiette l'animal comme ça il sera
pas défigurée dépêchez vous c'est un
berger allemand super ce sera vraiment
conquis lit pas sur les benêts monsieur
berger allemand vite vous êtes du même
coup le sanguin en berger allemand et
alors c'est mon chien va pas le laisser
crever non
le transsexuel c'est beau venez vite on
a le donneur là venez vite on a on à
l'andouillette
c'est beau le transsexuel vous c'est pas
vous monsieur g merci d'avoir choisi
dans l'histoire qu'est ce que je vais
revoir madame à la prochaine comme serré
la main et bijoux
au revoir et merci d'avoir choisi
lariboisière je travaille moi samedi
soir un double jeu c'est de la merde non
plus j'ai fixé à comprendre des astuces
des jeunes moïse était un peu d'art y
est quand même sans henry oui je dois
avouer quand même espoir en temps plein
un petit bonhomme tu avais bien
l'émission pas rester pas mal ces
défilés non pas fidèle mais bon j'aurais
le temps en temps sans samedi soir avec
ça donc à votre choix
voilà [__] il est collector ton pin's
[__] je te les chiens ont été les
changements allègent 123 [__] de
nommer les terrains à toi-même disent
même 10 voire 12 12
c'est mon service a levé sur bon tampon
sera typique des bijoux non comblés j'ai
rien compris
soit les papiers sur elle et valier
c'est le pv non mais on va tenter non
mais t'es là maintenant non mais tu veux
maintenant faites votre boulot jusqu'au
bout
c'est ce qu'on a le jeu vous annulez
toutes les prudes c'est ce qu'on a
oui odeur très forte
un procès non
c'est dans le rendez compte si à chaque
fois qu'on a qu'on se garent mal aller
d'elle et les prunes c'est ce qu'on a le
sont moins chauds seront te voir bah oui
je veux évidemment je veux tu vas même
pas la tire et c'est même pas la tire et
là puisque tu dois raconte d'ailleurs
que c'était la grosse question m est ce
que t bones où l'homme doit vous faites
ça vous n'avez pas envie d'avoir un
métier honnête il est honnête mon métier
autant si ces démunis t1
c'est bien vous m'offrez une gas
activités
pendant dans ces conditions je pense
qu'une petite relation est hors de
question
[Musique]
le roi non plus bien si c'est pour un
porno qui part au danemark tout de suite
de ce soir on l'envoie de suite la
bastille un petit bisou non ça va quand
même pas respectueux mettez vous mettez
vous bien en ligne jean-benoît meute en
ligne mon petit bonhomme
peut-on lire le préfet l'inspection ou
bien vous moyen un peu tendu comme un
bruit des biens robert bien robert super
moderne toinon bien ça paraît trop de
bruit à la barbe
on l'a dit n'avoir pas de barbe à
saint-christophe bien en ligne c'est
bien avocat manor au bistrot
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou